he has done an
incredible job on covid or covet 19 or
about
19 other names we can call it's got
probably more names than
anything else you can think of and he
was hit very hard
and he's and he hit back even harder
that's president trump praising arizona
governor doug ducey at the white house
over the state's coronavirus response
but many business owners in the state do
not consider it a success story
a deadly surge in june followed the
initial reopening of the state
cases are down now that restrictions
have been imposed again
mola lenghi shows us two businesses in
scottsdale arizona
struggling to stay afloat
almost 20 percent of the city of
scottsdale's
sales tax revenue typically comes from
visitors and by far the busiest season
is spring
before the brutal heat of summer sets in
but thanks to the coronavirus hotel
stays this past
march through may dropped by 72 percent
from last year meaning this spring was
anything but typical we have the spring
training and a lot of activities going
on
here in old town scottsdale and and
really hit us at a bad time
one minute you couldn't even find a
parking spot now
it's a ghost town it's a ghost town
correct yeah and that's really sad to
see
for the past 40 years eddie bernal and
his brother teddy have run their parents
pride and joy restaurants
my mom is from sacramento mexico and my
father is from soccer new mexico
a combination of those two you're
actually getting frank and lookies
but the bernal legacy doesn't stop there
eddie's 19 year old nephew teddy jr now
works the front of the house
through the most difficult time in the
restaurant's history
they're talking about a 90 decrease in
business 90
drop and that's that's ridiculous have
you guys ever
had a year this bad no never the
bernal's made some painful choices
laying off all but a handful of
employees they also adapted
after their state shut down all dine-in
operations
we've had to grow our to-go orders and
that'll only help us in the future
that kept them afloat until the dining
room reopened in may
but then arizona's alarming surge in
covid cases devastated
not just the family business but the
family itself
we lost my brother due to the coronal
violence
he unfortunately tested positive and he
went to the hospital
and he was there for roughly a week one
night
we got a call and saying you know
probably best if he comes you know come
see him real quick
your dad's absence is felt now
definitely
he was the face of the restaurant and
he's one of the longest people here
in old town and so everyone knows him
people come in every day and ask about
them and that's how we're doing
which is a little hard to hear big shoes
to fill i guess you can say yeah
how do you get up every day and someone
needs to do it and
to continue the legacy teddy bernal's
tragic death
is felt beyond the walls of frank and
lupe's in fact
you need to walk no further than across
the street to the blue clover distillery
to see how it impacted this community
when i heard about it obviously our
knees gave out beneath us
what are we walking into here weston
home has also been struggling to keep
his two and a half year old restaurant
and craft distillery alive
not only did he have to close his doors
so did the 200 local food and beverage
businesses carrying his chin and vodka
that killed probably 65 percent of our
distribution
right out of the gate right there and
how did you guys pivot what'd you do
so naturally the hand sanitizer was the
the easiest thing
it turns out all the equipment and
expertise needed to make booze
can also make hand sanitizer we had a
two and a half hour wait
for the first two weeks that we launched
it i didn't realize
that that many places were out of it at
that time
and the hands and the hand sanitizer is
what's keeping us floating right now
absolutely
we're just breaking even to keep the
doors open so that i can keep my dream
from dissolving and in keeping his
dream alive holmes innovation helped his
neighbors too
people would come for their hand
sanitizer and then come to us for a taco
or
margarita after when they could have
their line for hand sanitizing
that's when we'd be busy a tale of two
restaurants
both struggling with unprecedented loss
but both
determined to survive even here under
the blazing summer sun of arizona
for cbs this morning mola lenghi
scottsdale arizona
and blue clover distillery plans to keep
making hand sanitizer as
its business rebounds and in fact the
u.s chamber of commerce says that
there's 60 percent of businesses small
businesses in this country
are worried about closing permanently
because of this pandemic none of these
restaurants can stay in business or make
money
based on the number of people coming in
right now but those that are trying to
hold on
just hoping that rebound comes
eventually yeah wishing in the best of
luck